there was a woman who said her husband
on fire killed him for raping her
seven-year-old daughter she found him
murder him and yes she deserves a death
penalty if you support the death penalty
please take the light to the left if you
do not support the death penalty
take the light to the right first
statement step forward if you agree if
you do not agree if it is not true for
you stay exactly where you are having a
death penalty deters people from
committing crimes
I don't know that any regular human the
average human which is who were speaking
about would risk their life when when
that survival instinct is so incredibly
ingrained and so strong that's the
foundation of my entire argument the
reason why I stay on the left hand side
not because I feel that capital
punishment should be harder died dished
out to everyone that commits a crime no
I'm talking about the idea that it i my
opinion capital punishment as a
deterrent it influences the way people
behave look at Michigan Michigan
abolished California in 1958 look at the
crime rate in Michigan right now so let
me ask you guys your child grabs a vase
purposely you see them
grab the vase smash it on the ground
look you dead in the eye are they
deserving of a punishment
yes if are they aware of their actions
they're four years old
exactly they look do you right now okay
so I know what they did what's wrong do
you know what they're doing wrong yeah
they know what they're doing wrong it's
like a challenge you know they're gonna
continue to do the same thing over and
over
punishing that child you spoke to that
child people though might not have all
the information in the way that a
four-year-old doesn't have all the
information disagrees I really don't
remember any time someone was like you
know I really want to kill someone but
that death penalty man oh no it just
doesn't make sense to me that that's a
deterrent if anything a human connection
to someone like to themselves or their
family or someone they care about has
been the biggest deterrent in my idea of
course anyone can be rehabilitated back
into society
absolutely absolutely y'all um here's
the thing here's the thing I think this
is probably the most hippie part about
my whole thinking is that that unending
optimism for people that I know better
than to give up on someone I agreed with
the first half of the sentence but not
the second and then I think anybody can
be rehabilitated that doesn't mean that
they're going back into society there
are options for somebody to live a full
complete life and not be a danger to
society you also have to look at it with
child molestation cases I mean how are
you gonna send someone that did
something crime like that
that's so heinous and it's happened many
times where they releases people
constantly and they're still doing the
same thing no matter how much you try to
rebuild it rehabilitate someone they
also have to want to be rehabilitated in
order for that so we're assuming people
don't want to be rehabilitated that's my
whole point is that if you can believe
all some people want to be rehabilitated
though then you have to also believe the
possibility that they could redeem
themselves and do something amazing
after that rehabilitation happens for
those people that are just like past
rehabilitation are they deserving of
death is that what we've come to it
really it really depends on again
circumstances the circle what this crime
is but that's where we get into like who
are we to say who's deserving or not we
need to actually know their entire story
and who they are as a person their
upbringing what got them into that
situation their mental stability all of
those things can be taken more in
consideration but that goes to say that
once you read their book that you're
gonna be empathetic and it's clear that
they've taken this you know when
families have lost and kids do too
there's you know a higher most important
time to have empathy yes that's the
point
yep is when families do that to
understand what the family's going
through on top of what the person went
through everyone deserves a second
chance
personally you know I don't think
everybody deserves a second chance but I
do believe that there are people who do
deserve it so it just depends again like
I was mentioning earlier depends on what
kind of crime the committee if it's if
they killed somebody I don't believe
that they deserve a second chance but if
David's like a lesser crime like they're
stealing something from store like candy
or something like that or or a TV or
bike I do believe that they deserve a
second chance
here's the thing for me this is why it
gets hypocritical to me in this kind of
discussion where we all think about the
other person of the victim or something
like that in terms of second chances but
the whole biggest idea we really
confront this idea is if it was us where
would I want a second chance if I knew I
messed up on something however heinous
or big it was or howsoever small it was
I want that second chance for me and for
at least my family and friends that's
the least I want so that's why I know it
applies to everyone I think it depends
on what the second chance is that
doesn't mean that there is absolutely
entry into society and often means
giving someone their life just say yeah
I heard his crime that I had someone
raped then burned someone alive it's a
horrendous crime she just let them how
society that's too much of a second
chance but from what within the confines
of prison for such a heinous act that
you do get a little bit and just want to
go back to statement and people deserve
chances and does every single person is
over the second chance and my opinion no
because maybe what the crime that they
committed then you're talking about I
would love to have the chance to have a
second chance there's a difference
between I would love to have it and I
deserve it
I think I'm a little confused about
where it is that this line is drawn
because that makes the difference
between a second chance between life and
death between consideration and no
consideration I think I think it does
start with obviously the crime that you
commit there is a difference between
intentionally and unintentionally
that is the height of violent premed if
it was calculated I don't think you
deserve a second chance and in my
opinion for a crime like that no I don't
care I've no remorse I've no mercy for
anyone who kills anyone okay there was
um I spoke about this the other day
there was a woman who said her husband
on fire killed him for raping her
seven-year-old daughter she found him
murdered him
that was not self-defense that's perfect
it was premeditated engine yes and yes
she deserves it is she can uh no listen
she she can go through the legal
promotes you I understand that I
understand it but I don't you still need
to go through the legal process like
everybody else you don't take it into
your own hands to go and see like its
global justice like you're doing
something for the world like you are
removing a threat but that woman was
doing some global justice if I ever
heard it
that was not her right to do though it
that's not it you say that a jury of
your peers that we as citizens we as the
constituency we have that right then
what because we have numbers because we
have amazing process a death a death
penalty is a state a state sanctioned
homicide it still it still is a homicide
but it is decided by multiple people at
that point a good thing I think we need
to go above the legal system in this
dialogue because it was legal to have
slaves we'd have to go beyond this and
that was also alright he is transcending
what we're talking about
if someone genuinely apologizes for a
crime their punishment should be reduced
[Music]
um the thing is like of course it's the
hardest part of this concept this idea
is how do you judge someone's genuine
authenticity and in their apologetic
Ness right
I specifically remember a case Stanley
Tookie Williams this guy really
convinced me that he was apologetic for
his crime and the thing was he believed
he didn't commit the crime he was
innocent of the crime but he was still
apologetic for his past crimes that he
had done in his life and the things that
he did get convicted for so when I saw
that he made a children's book about
preventing other kids from actually
ending up where he ended up as a gang
member and and leader of the Crips I
believe that was enough for me where
he's actually going out of his way to
prevent future crime from happening for
other people I'm like all right I accept
your apology man I accept that
big time there's no way of validating
apology I mean like how do you know if
they're apologizing they're lying you
know there's a lot I mean they're people
who seem so genuine and behind you know
behind their eyes
you don't know truthful well I'll just
say a gang on gang violence just say
that a gang member did a hit on a house
of a leading the opposing gang member
and their family in to say well a
shooting he killed three people you say
eventually he did apologize it doesn't
matter he still killed someone and he
should still serve a life sentence with
it what if this person did so much to
redeem themselves or account for that
and actually show their genuine
apologetic mess behind
I don't care is that today they can in
murder they get life in prison no death
penalty they get white so if they became
Mother Teresa after this oh no I don't
person they could they could to see
their life behind bars I think it's
important to consider the the do stress
that this gentleman is under he's in
gang lifestyle in a gang environment
where he's gonna get his ass beat if he
does not go make this hit even in
military crimes yep like in world war ii
all those people that followed orders
yes they were guilty of those crimes
there are people who opposed or people
who tried to within his own group tried
to kill Hitler you still at the
individual chose to action you can't
count on somebody else to have courage
in the capacity that you do you can't
count on somebody to be as intelligent
or as brave as you are if we if we just
allow someone just to skirt by like that
we're giving a bad example to everybody
else in society and they're gonna think
that they can just repeat the same thing
and they're gonna get away with it I
believe that anyone can forgive anyone
given enough time I just want to say
that I mean once I read a story about a
mother that forgave the killer of her
child I'm like okay okay I believe in it
I believe anything is possible now
imagine your mother for a second sight
if someone were to kill your mother
would you be able to forgive that person
no eventually eventually a big hard
question was with her I'm anyone get it
yeah I'm gonna say I'm gonna say yes
with it sure with time unless you've
really experienced something like that
you won't know yourself really you only
know what you feel right now but unless
you were in that motion where it did
happen that that that mentality you
don't know way to traumatize people with
that question oh yeah first of all guys
a fast my question about your mother
iPod use for even given consideration to
forgive that person and for myself
personally and if something like that
did happen my mom I would find it so
hard for myself to forgive that person
who committed that act knowing that he
has destroyed my life has destroyed our
family's lives I think I would
eventually forgive but I know there's
people out there who would always hold a
grudge
I can't justify someone killing my
mother I mean I can't I don't I can't
see myself forgiving someone like that I
heard a great concept about it
immediately forgiving someone and
finding the reasons to forgive them
later like that that actually helped me
find peace of mind knowing that that's
the guaranteed like where I should end
up anyway you know so back to this
concept of our own mothers if my mother
were to commit murder I would vote for
her to receive capital punishment
I can't you know I can't sit here and be
a hypocrite
and say then I'm for capital punishment
if my own mother would commit a crime as
so heinous I would be for even for her
the law applies to everyone even my own
mother yeah if law enforcement abides by
a house to abide by the laws of US
citizens have to Bible oh yeah mom
should too
this is a very troubling thing for me
that anybody walked up to these chairs
because one it's something that I
questioned morally and emotionally about
our society that we're not already
crying or feeling some kind of feeling
about our own mother being on death row
because now we can easily imagine if we
take it one more step further that every
single person on death row is somebody's
mother or father or sister or brother we
can't escape that we'll be sad but at
the same time they committed a crime and
they have to pay for it why would I know
where the death lets me in the first
place on other crimes such offenders
what would it be for and what if there
were a sex offender themselves that
doesn't exclude them peas are my parents
yeah I am afraid that there are innocent
people on death row
I think we can all agree yep
yeah I've heard their husbands yes
there's no denying isn't the curve to be
more - yeah any more people the current
count I believe ever since uh President
Carter is a hundred people have been
found not guilty due to basically
witness is lying DNA and are such things
so a hundred people is not a small
amount
yeah if one person is innocent that's
enough to me to not trust illegal
settlements and on top of that in terms
of corruption racism all these kind of
things that affect our whole legal
system I don't know why it's a taboo to
say that like yeah we need to admit that
more and it's gonna be okay like let's
admit it and move forward okay
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa hey guys this is jason from jubilee
we hope you enjoyed another wonderful
episode of middle ground let us know in
the comments below what you thought as
well as let us know if you have any
ideas for any new episodes as you can
tell we're listening to you guys and a
lot of these are your suggestions so
thank you
make sure you click here for more videos
click here to subscribe and we will see
you guys next time
[Music]